[Music]
hey everyone this is Grandmaster
Stephens earth with tonight's Thursday
night lecture today I'm gonna be talking
about some more dynamics and sharper
middle games and how to find your way in
them so how to find attacking resources
how to pick the right plan how to make
things difficult for your opponent I'm
going to show you samples from a few of
my games some which ended well for me
some not so well so this first one was
from Charlotte this year actually I was
white against Andrew hung it had a
cattle on it started off a little badly
for me but bit by bit I was actually
getting to a typical nice Catalan
position and in this position
I played Queen e5 and my first thought
of course is rook a five getting the
pawn back but black has this annoying d5
taking his forest and pawn takes in this
position isn't so great for white
normally the bishop against Knight and
outside pasture would be very nice but
blacks d5 pawn blocks the bishop and
White's pieces are clinically placed
actually takes a little work just to not
lose the pawn so I decided before I took
on a5 I was going to play Queen e5 and
this move leaves a lot of possibilities
open it might help one idea how does
might help in a future attack
so if black tries to bring the Queen
down for example I can play rook a five
work a eight and if King up Bishop b4
and that'll actually be a very strong
mating attack so at this point I was
feeling pretty good I thought my
position was better and after almost any
move by black it is it's a typical
Catalan advantage but my opponent found
a very nice move idea as I said I
thought he couldn't continue his attack
because my counter-attack would be too
strong but what the move black found was
rook e1 so the first thing this does
want one thing it does is it prepares to
bring the Queen down to D 1 which is
blacks idea I thought this wouldn't be
possible because I would play rook a85
and if Queen D 1 show you a queen d1
then rook gave Czech Bishop b4 and
blacks going to get meet it if he tries
out five I just take with the bishop so
if originally I thought this wasn't
possible
we were both down to a few minutes and I
didn't see anything here but that's this
what happens let me ask you guys what is
the response here if white plays rook
takes a5 why isn't this a good move
right yep so 93 yeah that's a very nice
move originally I had thought that Queen
C 3 right white can't take the night
because the Queen hangs I thought Queen
C 3 addressed it but what's the problem
here
why is this no good for white good
so black to play and win
so as it turns out black has this nice
move rook see one white queen is rapidly
running out of squares from which it
protects the rook right if Queen d3
Queen I five and if Queen d2 what's the
final blow
good that 91 check discovered attack on
the Queen game over so actually after 93
whites forced to play takes on d3 takes
e5 and here white even can't why can't
even play Bishop c6 because Queen d6
forks two pieces so forced is rook c5
and this and you get this end game which
why it's almost certainly going to lose
and you can there's some drawing chances
perhaps but of course it's not what
White's looking for you'd have to be in
a very desperate position to play
something like this so rook e1
nice move because it fits in with blacks
attacking plans and in a clever way it
prevents White's so as it turns out in
this position again we're both well on
time so it was pretty difficult I
defined a nice resource Bishop b4 the
idea being no Queen D 1 because Queen B
a it will lead to mate and if rookie to
what is why play good
right bishop h7 discovered attack on the
rook and so if g6 the move I was afraid
of white simply sacrifices takes on e6
and here I'd looked at this position I
looked at Queen e5 and rook F I've
decided it wasn't great for a white it
was worse for white but crucially I
missed that white can take immediately
on a5 and if black takes which is the
best move white as a perpetual on e7 and
e8 yeah so there is still a draw here of
course but White's a hope of an endgame
advantage is gone and white has to solve
this whole variation with the clock
ticking and all that is very helpful you
know in a tournament setting so I missed
the immediate rook k5 and in the end I
played Queen c3 instead right basically
getting out of the knight d3 threat
which I didn't see a great way to do but
now blacks plans continue so this is his
reward for finding this rupee one it's
now the attack strikes rook takes a5
check check
yeah so White's king is forced to g4
white still has some threats it's not
quite over yet because why I can check
think of some good follow ups and after
Knight d5 as it turns out white is
objectively lost Kings really don't
belong on g4 in the middle game but it's
actually quite tricky if white takes on
c6 let me ask this you guys what is what
move looks most natural for black here
what would you play as black in this
position
I heard a queen f2 Knight f6 anything
else
f5h five yeah so that covers most of the
Moose the first move I looked at it was
actually f5 which to me looks the most
natural here but white here can create
some very serious problems because after
after King H for the whole thing I was
afraid of check weight black wins whites
Queen and all this is forced but
suddenly it turns out this position is
actually very difficult for black
despite the enormous material advantage
it is hard to avoid getting checkmated
so he asked this what would you guys
play here is black yes so queen h5 the
problem with queen h5 is check and
Bishop e8 yeah and suddenly that
material advantage evaporates
yeah it's not so simple so this was an
opportunity and our better moves for
black but this is a very natural one I
could have gone wrong f4 then f4 runs in
do check ok eight and now suddenly
you've got this diagonal Bishop e4 check
yeah so not so simple
the problem is after most things you
know for instance black is rupee one I
can simply check and check and so it
only turns out that box only defense is
queen g4 and even they are white as a
perpetual
and as it turns out the best move here
after Queen c6 is h5 it doesn't win the
Queen which is why I have five looks so
tempting to me but it means that box
King is still safe enough from the
surprisingly potent rook and Bishop
combination and after say king h4 queen
f2 whites whites just going to get in
trouble first so in the end I took on d5
missing this little opportunity and now
I can create complications but again
Kings don't belong on g4 in the middle
game even with just the Queen and rook
objectively there's no real safety check
now trying to escape to e5 my opponents
of going for material goes for this
she's still good and here again I
thought I was getting some counter play
I played the move rook e8 and so for a
moment it seems like white the King has
actually gotten some good defense
if Queenie six I thought I was getting a
very dangerous mating attack of my own
and it does look that way when my
opponent up again found a nice move so
what would you play is black here yes
g5
so that is an option it's actually the
second best move here problem is see if
I take a g4 check its the idea King III
runs into mate Queen c3 and Newark f2 to
king f4 I think it's still very
complicated Queen g5 king e5 the
probably that's the problem is once the
White King gets this far away if the
black rook isn't really contributing the
Queen's are not enough on its own so now
blacks the one that has to worry about
me
you can trade Queens there though and go
into a better in the game but the move
my opponent found was very nice d4 and
the idea basically is that you had seen
that if I take on e6 Black has the nice
move Queen g5 and as it turns out black
repulses whites attack creates a shell
of sorts with the King on h5 and now
there's no escape for white
I mean after most moves here Queenie six
forces a trade and then White's
perfectly happy in the end game d4
cleanup for now though blacks attack is
just too good because white isn't
creating serious counter play clean h4
and here we see the fork on e7 and f2
the rook g7 is the only try but sadly
blacks King again like any other
variation hides on h5 so King g5 you
don't want to allow this we need a check
so first King g5 draws the Queen back to
c1 King h5 no more checks and white
resigned so I think this is a very good
example of a complex middle game again
rookie one doesn't objectively win but
create serious problems for whites and
most importantly it's creating active
play for black black wants to attack the
King with this lineup and tactically
white can't counter-attack with the RIP
takes a 5 because Knight the 93 move we
talked about earlier
all right this next one I'm going to
show actually comes from the world youth
back when I won the under-18 this game
was in a very sharp line of the Scotch
they'll go through really quickly all
this is theory there's this Queen h4
move which leads to a lot of
complications a3 the best response and
the idea is after Bishop c5 g3 Black has
this move Bishop takes f2 and whichever
way white takes black is going to fork a
rook on either with either Queenie for
check or queen d4 check depending on how
I recaptures enough to check and then
show you another interesting variation
here white as king d1 takes a Knight d2
so in this variation white actually
stays down the exchange but first black
has to worry about the Queen getting
trapped here so this Knight c3 e4 is
forced it takes 53 Queen e5 is suicidal
because of Bishop b2 so you get this
interesting middle game where black is
up a lot of material the exchanging upon
but White has pretty massive
compensation with these bishops in the
awkward placement of blacks Queen so one
of several interesting lines there so in
the end I played king d2 instead the
idea being after Queen h1 I get a second
piece with Bishop g2 h2 and takes
so here White's all explored to develop
tonight's still on b1 and black has this
nice Bishop on a6 cutting through
White's position but of course the
materials a lot closer Bishop and night
for rook and two pawns castles takes on
c6 between h5 black activates the queen
c3 and King c2
yeah of course you don't want a King
hanging out on the D file for very long
and here here I'd say I got a little
materialistic I took on a seven I was
thinking in the lines of black one to
play Bishop c4 be four and then a five
basically trying to break through on
this B file because you know whites king
is still not particularly safe here
that's Queen side but a better way to do
it was just to play Queen c5 and then
this keeps a more active post for the
Queen and the active play here just
matters a lot more than the a7 pawn
first the a7 pawn is nice to have in an
endgame but then game is still a ways
away and here black directly
counter-attacks with g5 so had whites
Queen bit on c5 this e5 bond would be
defended and white could just move the
bishop back with no no problems Queen
takes a six be forced at this point
takes on f4 and Queen e2 and here we
have an interesting sharp middle game
blacks gonna get a bunch of pawns but
there's no g7 pawned so the dark squares
around the King are very weak and of
course this g3 pawn it's gonna take some
work to defend before g5 right not don't
take the pawn and fall for this very
famous tactic between g5 and in situ
so here we've sort of reached the next
stage of the middlegame
both Kings are very unsafe both sides of
active pieces but White's attack is
going to actually build up pretty fast
starting on the g3 pawn or maybe the H
file so here black needs to find the
right way to create play or create
threats would you guys play here as
black
Prine f4 and
so what if I play I could play rook f1
that allows rook f1 the problem is if
rook d2 to trade rooks then White has
this Queen g5 check at the end so I
think rook f1 gains a nice tempo for
white here okay so what else
I'll put it between two moves rookie a
torque d4
which one looks better d4
why do you say that
at very good so rook d4 was best with
the idea again of putting the other hook
on the D file it forces this rook d1
because of the the threats on d2 and
black and trade off rooks
greatly reducing White's attack actually
this is a good rule of thumb not just in
the middle game but also the endgame if
one side has a rook and minor pieces so
either rook and minor piece are open to
minor pieces against two rooks the side
with one rook wants to keep the rook so
this material balance is much better for
white with this other pair of rooks on
the board so black should trade this
rook and actually after that there's not
enough material to attack the King and
black and start to think about using
these past pawns for a win instead
though my opponent played a more
materialistic move for key aids looks
pretty natural this is a strong pawn on
e5 but the problem is the attacking
prospects are just more important so
root G 1 h5 and Bishop d3
and what my opponent probably missed is
that after Ricky 5y can play 94 now
there's some sharp tactics so first can
you guys see a tactical idea for black
here right rookie for work takes night
followed by Queen c5 check for King king
and rook so rookie for now here's the
question how does white respond
Queeny for queen c5 check and then
yeah so King b2 after King b2 Queen g1
and white just doesn't have enough
material why can do a perpetual by
checking continuously at queen h7 Queen
hae Queen d5 etc etc which is probably
what my opponent expected was that the
game would end in a draw after this but
you could so yes you're right you could
you could win the rook something like
this the problem is this cheap on is
worth is just too strong something like
Queen h2 check
it's a guard c7 and g2 and black should
be winning this at the best y can hope
for hope for here's another perpetual
yeah so my poni probably expected this
draw but if do you see something else
for white
so rook g3 at what point yeah rook g3
rookie to check
anyone else you so there's another
continuation for white here yep exactly
Queenie for Queen c5 check and now this
Bishop c4 this time white gets Queen g6
check in it has a pretty deadly attack
the Queen Queen g1 objectively black
should have gone in for this Czech Queen
f6 check now white needs to trade Queens
but white should win this endgame in the
long run who naturally thanks to this
past a pond just these bonds will be
blockaded but the game goes on instead
my opponent takes on g1 m g6 check
it's a King h8 is forced King f8 gets
mated check repeating a bit but now
Queen h5 King g7 and Queen f7 check so
White has a pretty easy perpetual here
if you guys can probably see Queen f6
check and so on but first question
actually
what should black do here king h6 or
King h8
you sinking eight-six
so wai-king age six over King h8
that's true on principle it's good to
keep the king out of the corner
and if white wouldn't be able to win
their work anymore that's true
very good yep yeah so correct actually
just read out this whole forest mate
after King h8 its forest checkmate with
Queen h5 check Queen g5 check if he
tries to hide in the corner White has
this force mate and Bishop c4
he goes to f/8 then there's this winning
variation Queen f6 and Bishop f7 is the
crucial move now if black tries to run
away his zone c7 pawn actually dooms him
check and mate yeah so there's this
whole forced win after King h8 an on
principle you generally want the King
right farther out with more squares
outside of the corner in this case so
King h6
would be the better try and here I move
I was thinking was Queen f4 check and as
it turns out so King h5 gets mated if
King g6 like does Bishop d3 check so if
black goes back to the seventh rank
white takes on c7 with check and ones
the rook but if black goes King age five
what does white do
yes
very good yep Queen f5 king h4 is forest
can get chicks gets mated and [ __ ] b2
yeah this is a nice quiet move crucially
it blocks queen of to check which has
been hanging in the air for a while
black has no checks and no defense
against the double checkmate threat so
instead forced is King g7 white takes
with check you don't want to give up the
rook with check so black should go up
takes c6 check and take b8 and this is
objectively winning for white but it's
not so easy to be sure of that again
especially in a practical game if the
engine will show you it's winning but
it's easier said than done
you can put you don't want to get
skewered right you don't play g2 yet
because check so something like this for
example this is winning for white but
it's also going to take quite a bit of
work and yes
so Queen b6 and Queen g1 that may work
as well let me see the other you have to
watch out for perpetual as though so for
instance black could play Queen d7 check
King before and say Queen b6 check the
problem being that you can't block with
the Queen because you need the Queen to
stop this Pawnee say king c3 Queen e5
I mean objectively I would guess this
probably is when okay actually here the
checks do run out to king c2 but maybe
Queen e7 check here would be better for
example you know objectively yes this
should be winning for white but of
course it's better than getting check
mated on the spot no there's plenty of
room for white to mess up
I like the Queen do one idea though that
wins as well yeah so the big the key
moment there in that game was finding
this Bishop c4 idea I'd say and just as
much on blacks part missing it it's
right here and more generally position
like this as well as the earlier one
where it took on a seven position like
this dynamics count for more than these
individual pawns of course the e5 pawn
looks like a very nice started to take
and it is but the persistent the
position is just moving too fast right
after rook e8 rook g1 you don't want you
don't want to allow white to win the
pawn with say Queen f3 after which
blacks King is wide open and that runs
us so into this whole variation with 94
and so on
and then of course the key being able to
calculate and see this Bishop c4 alright
I'm going to show this next game was
actually the deciding game in the Boston
just Congress a few years ago skip ahead
a bit so a pretty typical advanced type
French maybe white gets this huge pawn
chain black tries to break it down with
bonds on c5 nf6 here I slipped on the
move order a bit I played f6 black
should take on d4 first this way white
commits to taking back with the pawn
right away the problem with playing f6
first white gets this pawn which is
normal it happens in a bunch of these
positions and there's a an opening line
similar to this where black essentially
is gambit upon with something like
Knight f6 but usually the move C takes C
takes have already been played if black
takes now white can essentially keep
these strong bonds and take back with a
knight so a bit of a slip and move order
there when said Bishop f6 the idea going
for initiative instead of forgetting the
pawn back Knight d4 Bishop d5 d6 so here
this is the next middle game I'm going
to talk about White's up upon but his
development is a little awkward and his
Kings side is somewhat weakened and the
big problem is first of all white
doesn't want to leave the diagonal with
this Bishop but if Bishop e4 then black
can keep targeting it all the same
probably should have gone in for
something like this and again a bit slow
with development bit awkward but White's
position is also solid there's no huge
weaknesses so instead my phone I played
Bishop b3 you know not wanting to
retreat the knight made of three Merc f3
and of course black doesn't want to
trade Queens in a position like this c7
there should be three and so you ask
what would you want to do as black here
yes this is 2015 right yep
free up the bishop all right idea yep so
very close b6 b5 is the best move b6 is
also the right idea b5 specifically
because White's going to play Bishop d5
in response least that's the best move
you don't want it you do not want to
give a bishop free rein over this kind
of diagonal and Knight b6 is a likely
square for this knight in the future
right the f6 is held up by the bishop
so here Knight b6 and maybe night c4
next which b5 also supports yeah but
moving the b-pawn is key there's 55-48
your position like this black is aiming
to use this bishop as a target for tempe
it's something like Knight b6 or maybe
rip d8 you definitely don't want to
trade off LightSquared bishop here which
would greatly weaken blacks attack you
know in a position like this there is
certain positional compensation all
right you do usually don't want a dark
squared Bishop and a bunch of pawns on
dark squares but black is much happier
with initiative here
so instead rook b8 rook F 1 all right so
the bishop can come back Knight b6
Bishop f3 yeah and there's a few
different possibilities for black here
I played Bishop h3 right away d1 and
again White's position his development
looks good numerically right all his
minor pieces are output
these pieces are just awkwardly placed
in particular this night on e 2 the
problem is most of its good squares are
blocked by its own pawns and d4 is cut
off by blacks e5 pawn
so why does a hard time improving his
pieces further night see for the strip
see one now that rooks come out and
Queen d5 this move caught me off guard
usually in a position like this the
general rule of thumb is you don't bring
your queen out it'll just be a target
which is often true but this is a nice
exception my opponent found the recent
Queen H Queen t5 is good it's a similar
idea to the poisoned pawn variation of
the NA Dorf or Bach plays that Queen b6
Queen takes B to maneuver the idea is
the queen is actually quite a bit of a
thorn I did this one's going to kick my
bishop out of h3 with queen h5 maybe you
create threats on h7 defend the bishop
if it gets to a square where it's not
where it's safe basically then it's
going to hold up a lot of the opponent's
operations and that's what the Queen
does in the poisoned pawn as well so rip
d85 should be six there should be four
so it's creating some counter threats
actually g8 and Queen f3 this actually
isn't best for rias black as a response
we'll talk about in a moment I could
have played Bishop g6 and maybe f5
trying to create some squares for the
pieces I mean this night is still
awkward white would be much happier if
it could be on say e4 but the game goes
on and so after Queen f3 the next thing
we need to find is blacks got a very
nice edge and development in exchange
for this bond I'd like to generate some
threats but how do we do that what is
the best way because there are a few
candidates
very good yep rookie four is actually
crushing here between here
Bishop d5 and the basic idea is blacks
going to line up Bishop and Queen on
this diagonal and frankly with the pawns
and like this in a white slate squared
Bishop going
if black achieves that battery of Bishop
Queen the game is essentially over
there's no defense so the best try for
white is actually to keep using the
Queen I say if anything else black just
runs in and white will never finish
development here White's best try is
actually to use his own Queen and
similar theme of the annoying Queen to
try and keep black screen off the
diagonal when black wins with this nice
maneuver Bishop c8 and Queen d7 and now
Bishop b7 followed by moving the Queen
on the diagonal is inevitable so that
was the best way to do things in a
position like this which really calls
for an attack right with White's pieces
this passive especially on this diagonal
the LightSquared bishop at position like
this definitely calls for that exchange
sacrifice that e4 Bishop is doing an
extremely important defensive desk and
removing it would have helped a lot
instead I played something more material
this Knight d2 it's still good for black
but not nearly as good just playing to
safe essentially Bishop takes rook takes
and g4 and this is the move I missed you
know I was thinking that the attack
would continue Queen e7 is a serious
threat here and I was thinking white
still didn't have a good way to proceed
but chief or actually way could have
played this earlier in the game and
perhaps should have what's the night
come to this g3 square and basically
solve his development problems because
now it's too late to attack on that long
diagonal
I mean why can also entertain ideas of
counter-attack with g5 so black had way
too much for the pawn and now black is
giving up way too much to get the pawn
back bishop h4
g3 got fate b2 so black has gotten the
pawn back does have the bishop pair much
better to have it than not but now White
has a very secure position this efore
Bishop is much better than the g8 Bishop
but white actually does give it up just
to improve the Queen
no of course not rook f4 here when
there's back rank problems 4831 nice
little trick right take my queen get
checkmated that's right
get me ship g3
yeah so here I remember thinking for a
while about this decision and part of it
is that without this h-bond White's
defenses are that much less secure
without this night and then queen c8 and
here I was thinking that blacks threats
are very strong and they are dangerous
but objectively why can create some
counter threats so first of all the
Queen's under attack let me ask you guys
how would you continue as white here yes
Queen h5 okay so Queen h5 let's see I
might you just want to watch out for
something like this you have to
a trade rook T to think rookie - and
white hanging on that Queen and game so
that is one possibility
what else Queen f7
yep Queen f7 is the best move Queen H
vibes in the same vein my opponent
played Queenie sex so anyone tell me why
why this move isn't ideal
that's true yep so black can trade
queens and play-ay chicks when whites
threats are mostly gone add to that
most if you trade the Queens so you
mentioned Queenie sex queen a8 and the
possibility of Queenie for I actually
for the same reason I wouldn't want to
trade Queens and I would play your
earlier work f2 there oh yeah Queen f7
is best my Poteau played Queenie six
brought with the thought which is not
completely wrong that black has a
dangerous attack here right the Queen
can get to this long diagonal maybe
invade through g4 and h3 but the
counterpoint is that blacks King is
nowhere near safe either and the best
way to show that is Queen f7 and now
it's tough for black to continue the
attack because he has to watch the c8
square say Queen c6 or kf2 and black can
go rook d2 but right this is probably
just going to be a perpetual because
white has these threats forever and if
black plays h6 white at the minimum will
have an easy perpetual so it looks a bit
scary at first leaving the Queen's on
with this b2 rook but concretely it is
possible and it's the way white should
have gone the further point is that this
rook endgame just largely thanks to the
pawn structure and this b2 rook this
rook endgame is purely bad for white yo
maybe it's defensible but it is without
question worse and generally speaking
you want to aim for a complicated
position over just a clearly worse
position right and unclear was fishing
with both sides attacking is better than
an endgame a bad in game unless you're
absolutely sure you can draw that in
game til in this case black just takes a
two
g5 so the idea basically being that he
wants to stop black from making lifts
right playing H sex and making the King
safe but problem is the King comes out
this way and it looks a bit scary at
first but after just rook d3 why it's a
bit too slow like these pawns are going
to start getting taken and if white goes
for an attack check for example check
when the King just please and why it's
just a bit shy on material here one more
piece you could see this being crushing
but the two rooks just aren't enough so
g5 unfortunately just isn't fast enough
and after work d3 White's forced to do
something he doesn't want to do trade a
pair of rooks which the same as the
Queen trade it reduces the counter play
and makes the bad pawn structure count
for a lot more trade rooks and now the
pawns just go forward right in here
what's why it's best defensive idea
objectively this should be lost after
probably anything but how should white
fight on here is it certainly not over
okey sevens a pretty good move rook e8
yeah yeah both with the right idea you
probably want to follow up going by rook
d7 the rupee eight right yeah there's
you can't do too much from a passive
stance or B 3 a 5 your Kings still cut
off and rook a 3/8 is threatened yeah
the key thing right yeah the key thing
is rooks belong behind pass pawns and
they belong on active squares and here
the most important thing for white to do
by far was stationed the rook like that
after a five oh I can even think about
getting some counter play perhaps with
f5 and there's this nasty idea of just
checking with the rook continually until
the King finally leaves and then you
take g7 you know and suddenly the white
pawns are rushing towards the square and
even though you can pro2 connected
passed pawns sooner or later the problem
is that in a case like this it's later
it takes quite a few moves for these
pawns to get going with this roof
properly stationed so I mean black could
play I mean the slowest way and one the
you'll see in a few end games here and
there something like rook a 3 B 3 a 4
wreck a 2 B 2 a 3 and this comes up here
and there it is ultimately winning if
there's no counter play for a white but
as you can see it takes a lot of moves
like six or eight moves to get a
promotion from that and in the meantime
White's just going just not this bond
and come back and then start rushing as
f1
and if rook b2 among other things I can
look at rook a8 or just running these
checks so the key here is to activate
the rook and create counter play as fast
as possible to pass fonts too connected
passed pawns will win the game sooner or
later so it's important to create
calendar threats so King f1 trying to
get the King over towards the pawns
presumably just not a terrible idea in
theory but the problem is again that
won't be enough to draw the game it
might be a decent defensive idea but it
will be a losing one not King f7 it's
too late to activate the Rockwell's
could still play rook e5 here but that
is a worst version no you couldn't play
rook e5 sorry because of b3 b2 and
rekelen check anyone or k3 can't trade
rooks because the pawn will promote
before and a5 yeah
so here White's rook is much worse
stationed it's worse at stopping the
pawns and it's worse at creating counter
threats against black so g for again
this would be much stronger if white
could attack blacks king in this g7 poem
rook d3
so now the pawns just go forward I'll
show one last tactic here okay 583 King
d1 and here what is the best way to get
the pawns forward how does black win
this game so a 2 then rook takes a toon
[ __ ] 1 White's king with the King on e
1 this would be a very nice win but
White's just in time here for H 2 so you
can go into this Bannen game sometimes
something like this is winning but here
I believe that white will just play here
and the problem is blacks King can't go
to f4 the spawn promotes same thing if
you go h6 white takes and there's no way
to win these pawns without giving up
your pawn yeah so sometimes trading
rooks like that is a good simplifying
technique if it weren't for ya if it
weren't for losing the a pawn if you
could do this without losing a pawn that
would win but in this particular case
White's King is just a little too close
alright so how should black win this b3
and rook k3 so b2 this is a nice idea
the thought base would being right if
black takes if white takes the rook like
it's a clean winning endgame but what
does white do here right we're gonna
ignore this rook and we're gonna gain a
crucial tempo through a case of Jack and
now the pawn is stopped
yeah so that doesn't quite work so what
should black you here
b3r okay three right rook hitch one Jack
this is another idea worth knowing the B
3 pawn keeps the king away for just that
one crucial move so white has to move
the King up D - are you - and now the
pawn goes through and of course it's
much too late to do any of these checks
ice king just runs forward that's what
black played so after B - white resigned
alright so any questions about that game
I mean the key lesson starting from the
first game you think about what you want
to achieve in these positions there were
some bad traits like that Queen trade
for this the bad Queen trade in this
game for example the position like that
the the threats balance each other right
both sides have dangerous threats
against the other
but in the end game whites were spawn
structure and less active rooks just
told with no consequences and similarly
the other the missed opportunity of rook
takes e4 right in a position like that
with a wide open long diagonal and an
advantage in development getting
something like that is just positionally
instinctively recognize it's a crushing
advantage right that's the kind of move
that honestly I wanted to play it safe
but generally speaking you can even play
moves like that without calculating any
variations
um I won't play it next time but I mean
there are there others somewhat similar
variations you can play that lead to
those two Matic ideas you want to break
down the center at all costs it worked
out well in the end created a lot of
practical problems yeah
so anything else all right thank you
very much
you
[Music]